look i was excited to be here to talk
basketball but the world has
dramatically changed in the last 48
hours
tuesday all eyes were here on george as
history was made
raphael warnock became the first african
american to win a senate race in the
state
and john ossoff another democrat won the
state's other senate seat
these were landmark victories that both
the nba and wnba
played a part in but things quickly
shifted wednesday
to washington d.c where supporters of
president trump
tried to disrupt the certification of
the electoral college by storming
the nation's capital it was a shocking
and brazen attack on our democracy
as these domestic terrorists breached
security
and invaded both the senate and the
house
five people lost their lives including a
u.s capitol policeman
as the world watched in horror now the
reaction was swift
around the nba as players knelt in
solidarity at
the miami and boston game and also
with the pistons taking on the bucks and
finally
the clippers and the warriors game
and there was lots of reaction from
around the league from both players and
coaches
when you saw the protests in the summer
uh and you saw the riots
uh or more the the police and the
national guard and the army and then you
see this and you saw nothing
you know it basically proves the point
about
a privileged life you know uh in a lot
of ways
um you know i'll say it because i don't
think a lot of people want to
uh could you imagine today those
were all black people uh storming
capital and what would have happened
reminds me of what dr martin luther king
has said
that there is two split different
americas and one america you get to
you get killed by sleeping in your car
selling cigarettes or playing in your
backyard
in another america you get to storm the
capitol and
no tear gas no massive arrests no
none of that describing those people the
same way you describe someone who just
stand there and make a chant and say we
want justice we want peace stop using
the same word it's disrespectful it's
ridiculous
um and it's shameful you know to
to keep calling them protesters ah
protesters are
terrorists chuck it was a
very different 48 hours your thoughts
well
uh i sit there and watch that and i was
i was in shock like like wow this is the
united states
and they're storming the capital and i
blame everybody in the capitol
that's who i blame i blame that fool up
there and d.c was the president first
and foremost
but these these politicians have divided
this country
into republicans democrats uh
conservative
liberal and they have destroyed our
country
we can't have a civil debate anymore
uh you got to be on one team or the
other team it's like this election down
here in georgia
i'm sitting i've been coming here the
last couple weeks now like well if we
don't put
two democrats or two republicans in
there it's going to end the world i'm
like
you serious they're going to disagree
that much
the greatest country in the world that
it's going to come down to two people
or all hell's going to break loose our
political system has become a joke
uh i i i'm not a fan of the president
but
i blame those people who were in the
senate in the house
because they have divided this country
to the point where
one vote gonna dictate whether one party
gets screwed or the other party gets
screwed
and that ain't right so i blame them the
president has made it fashionable and
cool to be a bigot
he's made it very cool to be a bigot but
i blame the people who they storm
for the situation we're in today
kenny well i think we we've all heard
a lot of different people talk about uh
you know the privilege
we've talked we heard talk about you
know comparing it don't compare it to
protesters as
draymond said we've heard all those
different things but i think people who
who follow our show and watch
me they know that i i try to analyze
the situation and not always have the
first emotional
emotional response because of your first
promotion response you know
i'm not surprised that it happened i
know child said i'm not surprised
i i've been at dinner taters with tables
where
we said man if this happens they're
going to store in the capital or they're
going to burn the white house down i
think every
black family has heard that kind of
phrase sure so
we we understand that but what this
really about and i think this is
important
to get a million dollars worth of games
so to speak is it's you know
what were they angry about
the vote see we they want us to divert
to the storming
they're angry the things that we protest
against about
life and death about you know citizens
of life and death of black and brown
people
they're angry because of the vote and
was willing to list risk for people's
lives
for that and was willing to risk
being incarcerated behind the vote
so that's important for us to understand
how important that is to people
like that in that time of mind frame so
the vote is the most important which
leads to what group economics
which then leads to systematic racism
that's why they were climbing the walls
they weren't climbing the wall you have
to go back to why they were mad
because in georgia it became a blue
state
in california they're voting now oh if
you get out of if you if you
if you're a federal if you come out of
prison you're down to vote now
you know those are the things that are
systematically changing the country
you know so million dollars a game
realize why they were angry and not the
emotion of what happened
and say now arm your kids with education
arm your kids with voting arm your kids
with group economics because
those are the things that people are
dying over and start
the triple trickle effect of you getting
shot in the street
defund the police thought process all
those things remember
why they were angry
it's obviously we saw an attack on our
country
an attack on our democracy but for all
the people that
sit back and and and think in 2022 that
there is no white privilege
you saw yesterday if you have to ask
yourself what if that was black people
you know there's a problem uh you know
we
we protest we chant we do this
we get beat up they call the national
guard we have the courage to say
we come in wednesday we come on coming
on wednesday and what do you do tuesday
night you call the national guard
you have them standing there at the
steps we marching we're doing whatever
we still get beat up you got these cats
the privileged cats they run in in the
capital which is not supposed to happen
and they get to do do what they want and
it's still going on it's unfortunate
that it's still going on but
you know good thing about us is we're
starting to make changes so now the
people that we're making change with
they they have a job to do they have the
job to make sure
things start to turn around and you know
become how we want it you know i'm
i'm disappointed that i saw that but my
thing is
how you let this guy get in nancy
pelosi's office
put his feet up and go like this how
does that happen and you can't let a
brother just come up to one cop
and say one thing without getting mace
billy club or anything so that's what
white privilege is for all the people
that sit back
and act like there's no white privilege
we have
a couple of ceos we have one or two
black billionaires there's you know
we've
we've come a long way well we haven't
come long enough i think it's important
to remember the history that got us here
1877 the compromise of
1877 and that electoral crisis when all
the soldiers were pulled from the south
and it ended reconstruction
and that instituted jim crow and we have
lived
in that state and it's gotten better but
we're still trying to
fix that moment and hopefully this is
the beginning of fixing that moment
because that history has lived with us
here in america and i propose
are we going to break okay when i play
close you know cause kenny we come from
certain neighborhoods where
people have to do what they do right now
i'm violent get caught with a bag they
get 20 30 years right
they got to do what they got to do
they're non-violent they've you know
exhausted every options
not smart enough to get a scholarship
without but they see opportunities to
drop off a bag and get paid they get
caught they get 25 30 years
all them people that storm storms a
little capital they should get 25 30
years they should get harsh sentences
for doing what they did
and there have been multiple arrests
already they are identifying those
people who
reached the council i want to see 25 30
years yeah